welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and we've now gotten our first
official look at Venom 3's logo and it
is exponentially becoming the craziest
film Sony Marvel has ever made
considering all the weird places Madam
Webb and Craven are taking us in the
unresolved questions we have after Venom
Let There Be Carnage and morvus who is
really pulling the strings of the sonye
and how many of those 80 billion light
years have hide mind among symbiotes and
different universes will it take to
screw in a light bulb above God of story
Loki's head in that key blur elf Tree in
venom 3 cuz I assume he's going to make
a cameo in it because crazier things
have happened hey cheers this is the
sneak peek where we will take the
temperature of whatever we are watching
while we look ahead into the next week
of nerdom joining me my co-host Jessica
Clemens you not only did you say a
mouthful and a lot of very important
details but the most important detail
was the kebler elf tree and you calling
Loki basically a kebler elf he is he is
insane of you don't light any fires in
that tree we saw in the movie Elf that's
how people burn that's don't do that but
hey if you need some water to put out
any fires or quelch any thirst uh thank
you to air up for sponsoring this video
you may notice jica I hydrating from
these air up bottles they have these uh
little scent based flavor
Rings yeah look I got to call it out
I've been drinking from this Arab bottle
this whole video and I can't pretend I'm
not AR up sponsoring today's video and
thank you for that but I also stole this
one from the office and now I'm the one
in my friend group who's like wow
water's kind of great huh I wasn't
always that way Arab did it to me and
like good because I feel so much better
drinking water all day than I did after
six-pack of like Diet Coke you know what
I'm saying Arup uses your senses of
smell to make your water delicious
there's no sugar calories or junk making
Arup a healthy alternative to sugary
flavored beverages it's just plain water
but Arab's revolutionary hydration
system lets you choose what flavor you
want it to be from a variety of tasty
flavor pods you just pop the pot on your
air up bottle and activate it then sip
don't tip the bubbles carry up the scent
to your nose and your brain makes the
flavor isn't that insane how our bodies
work my favorite flavor is the orange
Vanilla swirl it just reminds me of like
a sherbet on a nice sunny day and it
tastes delicious and I know it's just
the scents in my nose to get an Arup of
your own just click the link in the
description
below I'm eating ice cream or am I this
seems to be like the Venom official
title logo for the third Venom film this
comes to us by way of a collider it
looks like there's a Venom 3 and a three
is an exponent which you could take this
a couple different ways right you could
do is this like Venom cubed like Venom
is now on an x a y and a z axis into
threedimensional space which he already
is but is this like another dimension of
Venom that we're getting could it be a
nod to the Alien 3 title logo the David
Fincher alien film where Ripley goes to
the prison Colony before we started
rolling Jessica and I started debating
the alien franchise it's insane that you
think the second one's the best one I
don't I think the first one is the best
but second one is the second best I mean
yeah it's second place for a reason the
fir I thought you meant the second one
Oh I thought you meant the second one
was better than the first one I was like
I am not no offense to that little girl
she's amazing I am not choosing that
plot over the first one the first one
was so good what was it AEL who did the
first one who did the second well James
Cameron did the second one first one was
really SC and that's enough to tell you
why the first one's better and that's
all I'm saying there wow wow wow wow wow
so think that the guy who directed
prometh and alien Covenant is a better
director than the guy who did Titanic
and no okay you're leaving out some
other forms like the the worst of the
Terminator movies the worst of the
Terminator movies James C you talk about
James Cameron James Cameron made the
best of the Terminator movies T2
Judgment Day is by far it's the only
good Terminator movie I would say okay
now we have the first Terminator is not
that good Terminator 2 okay Terminator
Okay um I don't know I don't know if I
are I don't know if that's actually I
would stand on those grounds ter
Terminator 2 has some shitty dialogue
and it's enough to make me be like I
hate this movie oh well you can't I mean
look all of James Cameron's movies have
some shitty dialogue the guy just is
kind of weird but like you have to just
like let go of that and just like no
I've seen the abyss I've seen the abyss
yeah we've all seen the abyss I've seen
that dialogue he's good at math and that
is great of him he is a lunatic of a man
and I'll give him that he just tweet
when the submarine crashed he tweeted
immediately and was like well here's
what you did wrong and I said James read
the [__] room right not not not James
Gamer's best I think we can agree not
his best
moment we
got sorry we' got off the reals we're
talking Venom 3 so just to catch us up
from what happened and Venom Let There
Be Carnage you know Woody harelson
played Cletus Cassidy the serial killer
he escapes they have a big brawl and the
movie ends basically I'm summarizing so
much of that movie because it's not like
you guys care that much what happened to
Venom Le there be Carnage there was just
Carnage and they fought and then they
ended up with Eddie and Venom on a
Mexican beach as they were talking to
each other they learn to finally come to
terms with the lethal protector
superhero name which gets referenced in
the Spider-Man no way home post credit
scene where they were talking about Iron
Man and Hulk and Thanos and he's like
wait uh you think that's a better name
than lethal protector like they're still
debating the lethal protector as a name
really the one line comes from that
Venom Let There Be Carnage post credit
scene where he says 80 billion light
years of hive mind across U multiple
universes that kind of I think it was
establishing that the Venom symbiote has
the same kind of arachno frequency
that's fueling it as does like the
spider-verse and Spider-Man um across
the spiderverse Miguel O'Hara's Canon
event uh school project that he
displayed definitely showed various um
Venom symbiote infections that uh what
were considered Canon events within the
spiderverse no humanoid poly Multiverse
is his term for it and one of them what
included Toby McGuire pulling the venom
goo off his face in Spider-Man 3 so I
think it's establishing that like the
the Venoms are through this like Web of
Life and Destiny connected to the
spiderverse even if in the Tom Hardy
Venom films he did not get his powers by
jumping onto like a Spider-Man at any
point it just directly latched on to
Eddie
Brock 100% but the point is somewhere
else he did and I guess that was enough
to get inducted into the citizenship
test of all of the spiderverse did
wasn't there a piece of symbiot that was
left at some point in Carnage in the MCU
in the Spider-Man um no way home post
credit scene after he goes back to his
Universe there's a little bit of Goo
that's left behind oh my God is that the
cute I think like yeah the idea is that
there are like pieces of Venom that are
scattered across the Multiverse and that
Eddie Brock's little human brain is just
going to get overwhelmed with like
alternate life Paths of other Venoms and
other things that have happened and that
he's gonna like he just when he started
to come to terms with this other Venom
voice in his head now he's gonna have
voices from every Venom toer Grace Venom
from somewhere else that's just gonna be
echoing through his mind I get that like
Tom or not Tom well no Tom Holland had
like a three-part origin is getting like
a three-part origin story right he got
three movies that is basically like oh
here's the beginning of what Spider-Man
is and for Venom it feels kind of like
the same way with the Symbio it feels
like we're just getting the origin story
the third episode can't be another like
origin kind of story right it has to be
supporting what's currently going on so
do you think that yeah that's why I'm
like it has to be do you think the I'm
I'm trying to acknowledge that maybe
this is the introduction of like they're
actually gonna go fight null right or
like we're gonna see it oh yeah we're
getting ramped up for that or something
that can continually because as Madam
web's coming out and we're making the
web of the spiderverse I'm like they
have to find they have to make the jump
the at the third Venom movie you guys
got to make the jump you can't be
standing here still right we need to
dive into Cosmic horror um and yeah a
battle with null makes some like makes
perfect sense that's where I want things
to go as well I don't need like an Eddie
Brock origin story we already saw enough
of an origin story but I think what he's
going to learn in venom cubed whatever
we call it is that his story is not like
the classic Eddie Brock origin story
that he was kind of an aberration from
the norm and much like Miles Morales
realizing that his life story was like
an ation from the norm like and I think
I hope the MCU says the same thing that
an MCU without X-Men was an aberration
from the norm um and that all these
things just because you know in the past
the studios weren't really working
together and they couldn't have certain
characters in that Universe it made like
these incomplete universes but I think a
really cool way that they could fix that
is just by saying like yeah in your
Universe you were incomplete but there
is another Universe out there that was
complete um and I think that's what
we're going to learn about Eddie Brock
in this movie too like you you should
have been in a universe that had a
Spider-Man in it he was supposed to be
like your mortal enemy and you just
don't have that you are now haunted by
these like elor battles between elor 's
and other like young photographers who
work for the Daily Bugle and that's G to
freak Edie out do you think so but
there's no way to put him back in the
right Universe he's gonna just die I
think he'll stay in his Universe um but
I think his mind is just going to be
like you know like in everything
everywhere at once how her is just Lea
frogging around different versions of
herself I think that's kind of what
Eddie Brock is going to go to this keeps
happening in Hollywood where big movies
come out and like it happened with
Inception right after Inception there
was like three to four years of a bunch
of movies that were all trying to do
what Inception did absolutely and none
of them were that good um I think
everything everywhere at once was like
the first really really good Multiverse
movie that was in live action that like
did it well and the rest of Hollywood
just kind of recognized its greatness
and so we're going to start to see that
play out in other movies that try to
also do the Multiverse they're going to
be like oh why don't we just do what
they did and everything everywhere at
once and I think they're going to pull
Tom har through that kind of Journey
that Sony sorry not not not to not not
at all to be negative to Sony you guys
I'm so sorry but like you think the
Sony's gonna try grabbing kind of what
in everything everywhere all at once did
in venom that'll be in I could see Ed
Hardy because he's co-writing it I could
see Ed Hardy being like I can do this
and I'm
like I think like Sony already has like
a functional Multiverse landscape with
the the into the spiderverse across the
spiderverse and a lot of people say well
those were as good of Multiverse movies
if not better yeah they they have been
really good but in liveaction it needs
to kind of take a different texture and
they want to ground especially if you
have like a star like Tom Hardy is they
want to figure out how do I internalize
that in my performance I don't think you
could just show Tom Hardy into the
spiderverse or across the sperse and
he's going to know how to like perform
that in front of a camera but if you
show him every everything all at once
he's gonna be like oh yeah I know how to
do that yeah I know how to oh I know how
to do that that was my British accent
that didn't come out British at all I in
your video when you started talking
about the Web of Life which I also talk
about in my video I was like that makes
more sense for the live action to get
into and like keeps this not the streams
but it keeps them distant for right now
the animation can keep doing what they
want to do in the Sony Marvel Universe
and we can the live action is going to
touch on the web of life and I could see
do you think that Venom you kind of said
it with across of spiderverse so Venom
as a symbiote would be in the same Web
of Life as the Spider-Mans would be and
maybe and uh Madame Webb could see that
and see him being in the wrong Universe
yeah I don't know if Madame Webb is
going to be like actively controlling
everything but I think she's going to be
like just playing the harp strings as
best as she can she's GNA be guing what
if it was his Divine Destiny to just be
the Symbiote do you think they guide the
Symbiotes too not just the radio AC of
spider bites so like I I think they do
they get
symbiote yeah it's going to be
interesting like Venom 3 has the
opportunity to uh establish the origin
of that by saying null is kind of like
tied in with what whatever the Web of
Life Of Destiny is yes because there's
enough universes where Venoms exist only
because they first latched onto a Peter
Parker in Eddie Brock that that like
tipped the scales in favor of all
symbiotes who come to Earth everywhere
being part of that web in life and
Destiny it's it's almost like um uh
racial profiling from the point of I
don't know this probably isn't a good
example but it's like well we know in
the in the the Multiverse enough of
people like you tend to have to be
bonded to a Spider-Man first so that's
enough that's Eric stop the example my
throat was even like stop it just stop
talking that you were getting choked out
like the [__] man in the black suit
and the Mad web trailer um I'm glad you
acknowledge that I I was like halfway
through I went this is the third person
he's choked underground and I need
someone to tell me I'm not crazy and you
were like he keeps choking people you
were genuinely like why is he keep
choking people stop choking people we're
talking about Ezekiel Sims everybody in
this trailer Ezekiel Sims just he has
one move he picks up women by the neck
and just ch and throws them down and
chokes them it's the I don't and I don't
I don't know I don't maybe once we see
the movie we'll recognize maybe he his
hand to throat is just the easiest
option for him but I don't think it is I
think it's just R we we're talking about
Madam web we should remind everyone some
updates we got Madam web we saw this
clip of Ben Wyatt from Adam Scott uh who
we're pretty sure is playing Uncle Ben
in this movie we don't know for sure but
roll the clip you have a winning
personality I guess I got yours by
mistake to go to Johnson's laugh is just
not doing her any f
leave her alone leave her
alone that's right she did all of us a
favor by going after Ellen she in our
hearts for she did what everybody in
Hollywood was afraid to do and she that
was take down Ellen
degenerous how was the party I wasn't
invited actually no that's not the truth
Ellen you were invited I don't think so
ask
everybody we should uh also acknowledge
according to scooper Daniel rpk Madame
Webb might have no post credit scene
which big missed opportunity Sony
because you know for a lot of people
that's the only reason they go see these
movies okay hear me out if null is like
the the main goal the like of the
biggest the biggest of all big bads this
is all being orchestrated to somehow do
null it would make sense that like Venom
I keep thinking that Madam Webb is gon
to be like the most the biggest thing
for us right now because it's
introducing just like a different look
at the spiderverse it's a different
thing if she's the one that watches
people get guided into being bitten
that's insane watch it be in venom we
actually get that like post credit scene
that's very important and it's showing
like oh no's coming oh he's coming he's
on his way and then it doesn't need to
be like addressed in Madam webs movie
but also what if they're lying what if
they're lying and there is actually a
post credit I mean it may just be like a
press thing like um Sony's done this
before where they've shown movies to
press but don't show the post credit
scene yeah what would you want the post
credit scene for Madam Webb to be null I
want it to be Web of Life and Destiny
and or null
um now we're not GNA get that [__]
yeah we're not not Madam web not in
Madam web I don't really know who
they're making Madam web for but it's
definitely not people who know who null
is do we not know who null is I guess
people who n is well yeah because it's
our job but do you think the audience
has seen all of the Sony verse so far
does not know who nol is they don't know
like I think it's possible I think
there's a lot of people who go see
Spider-Man movie I mean null is a pretty
deep cut there's a lot of people in the
comments who are like I definitely know
who null is null is to be of God
everyone and that's it it may I was like
I just assumed people knew what it was I
I don't know Madame web seems like I
feel like there's more to it that we're
not the trailer and I get into this in
my next video the video that came out
yesterday that it's very confusing the
trailer is so much to take in there's so
much Exposition in it but it's also cut
with time jumps and you're just like
what am I looking at and then once you
finally figure out what you're looking
at a new thing pops up and I after
researching it I was like oh I get what
they're trying to do and especially if
this is like her origin if we see her
later as the as The Madam web that you
want Eric the one in the chair that is C
I want old lady Joan Lee Stanley's wife
voice the animated version of the
character I want crazy old lady in a in
a machine chair who's from the
Multiverse that's what I want and that's
the thing is like if I want Madam web
yeah this origin is great I then the
next maybe not the next one but
eventually we will get the older version
of Madame Webb where she's proficient in
her powers and it won't take her messing
up a bunch seeing fragments and maybe
lying about what she's seen and I think
that's what the first this movie is
going to be more about is just like oh
how she came to power if they just threw
Madam Webb into the Sony verse we
wouldn't know the hell she is only
people that watch that old animation
would and I mean that's fine but it's
like you we do need her origin story we
do need a little story I just I I think
this Sony keeps doing this Sony loves to
cast young hot thin
Stars it's like they saw social network
and they're like and that Andrew
Garfield's great we will only cast
whatever this generation's Andrew
Garfield is in everything no it they are
yeah they did no they are doing it they
love it they love that CW look they love
making their teenagers the hottest
things they want everyone be handsome
and sexy and I think it's like an
international thing I think it's like
because Sony's an international company
that there's just people who infuence
these decisions who are like yeah there
may be nerds in North America who like
that but are people in Singapore going
to line up to see this ago no bounce
them put Emma Stone in this movie put
Emma Stone in this movie because I just
think if you were to pitch to like just
an audience who goes to see these movies
are you gonna watch a Marvel movie if it
is Dakota Johnson talking to uh Adam
Scott about something that just seems
like this weird like they're both
paramedics or we're going to put Helen
mirin in a crazy steampunk chair as she
screams about Cosmic webs but again we I
guess I guess you could would line up
for that movie that's true I guess you
could throw I was say I guess you could
throw her in just as that Helen mirin
and then people would be like I don't
know who this character is but I love
her this this is the best thing I don't
know if a full movie was necessary but
Sony doesn't have any TV shows so it's
like what what were they going to do I
just don't need these characters to be
sexy like I don't need them to be sexy I
don't care I want them to be like freaks
let's rewind the clock to the Sam Ry
Spider-Man which I'm working on a video
right now that just explores the whole
history of how Toby McGuire came into
that role Toby McGuire they had that
trailer where he like got shredded but
Toby Maguire looks kind of weird I was
such good C I was about to ask I was
like by Freaks you mean Toby Maguire and
then I had to catch myself because he is
a freak don't be he got this interesting
face and an emotive and expressive face
but Hollywood used to do that they cast
will and Defoe and Toby Maguire as the
leads of that movie and the most boring
character in it was James Franco like
they didn't cast James Franco as Peter
Parker they cast Toby you know like we
used to do that we used to roll the dice
on weird looking people I love this
logic of like and if you put a pretty
person in it make them the worst
character make them the boring yeah make
them the villain make them the friend
give me my odd faced people back also I
guess Toby McGuire is just a weirdo to
be fair to be fair it's why Robert
Downey Jr works as Tony Stark is Robert
Downey Jr a handsome fellow his face
works on screen you know they have these
weird algorithms where they like measure
the ratios of your face and all this
stuff like they aren't putting this face
in a movie there's a reason they put
Matt Pat in a movie Five Nights at
Freddy they'll never never put Eric V in
a movie my face is just stupid looking
and they don't want to put it on a
screen I would ruin the movie if you put
me in it looks so handsome he looks so
good in that Cameo like yeah of course
you can put him in a cameo are a pretty
me I eat too much junk food you do eat
too much candy but you are a pretty boy
don't put me in a movie for the love of
God don't put me in a movie I don't like
that our I do like that our video and
don't like that our video is criticizing
hot people
I'm not criticizing hot people I'm
criticizing the studios for only caring
about hot people like uh Robert Danny Jr
though he's a an oddl looking fellow
he's got these interesting features that
are not like he's not like Chris Evans
or Chris Hemsworth he's just kind of
weird looking he's just kind of weird
looking did you also see the runtime for
Madame web yeah it's the longest but
it's only like just shy of two hours all
of these movies have been so short I
think they know why hey and we're
criticizing Sony but they're not
sweating it like they keep making these
like hour 45 minute movies that just
play again and again and again in
theaters and enough people see them and
they're low enough budget and they're
making money from them and I think
that's why their budgets are all pretty
like I think they're all like just north
of a hundred thou or hundred million
dollars for their budgets and they look
it but the movies make money you said I
notice but my mom doesn't and she thinks
Jason mimoa is hot uh that's why I went
and saw Aquaman 2o my mom was like I
just really want to see Chas of Baba and
I was like okay fine the entire movie
she was going
oo those people those companies know
what they're doing they get people like
my mom who just tune in because it's a
giant hot
man all right we want to tease the Slate
coming out on New rockstars this week on
Monday we have our breakdown of X-Men
the Last Stand it's the third in our
X-Men rewatch series and you know what I
know a lot of you aren't crazy about
X-Men the Last Stand but this video is
so good we go into so much there's a lot
from this movie that I feel like they're
going to bring back for the MCU
surprisingly speaking of Aquaman 2 we're
also going to do a breakdown of Aquaman
the lost kingdom because it's coming out
on digital and I didn't have a chance to
see it when you know it came out in
theaters because baby was here and I'm
not going out to movie theaters right
now you're crazy but uh we're going to
do a breakdown of that and then
following that I think we owe it to our
viewers to do a full assessment of the
dceu the whole history of it really what
went wrong with that franchise because I
think there's a lot of bad takes out
there of like well they did this wrong
or they did this wrong and there wasn't
enough MCU or was like too much trying
to be the MCU and I think there's like a
couple specific reasons that people just
don't talk about and that's why we're
gonna do that and then we're also going
to try to do a breakdown of the Monarch
series from Apple TV plus so I because
that's going to tie in directly with uh
Godzilla X Kong and uh there's like all
these like timeline implications so we
want to do like a breakdown of
everything you need to know from Monarch
Legacy of monsters that is a diverse
week of content that is everything
you're hitting almost every corner and
then we'll probably have some like MCU
Theory about like who pooped in thanos's
mug and you're going to love it one
thing I want to ask you about Jessica is
you touched on the idea of null that
Sony should bring in null but if you
look at Sony's slate doesn't it seem
like they are so afraid of going into
Cosmic horror something that I talk
about in the Xmen The Last Stand uh
breakdown is like how other than the MCU
and what they tried to do in the DCU a
lot of these other superhero movie
franchises are like so insistent on
trying to keep things grounded within
grounded logic because they're trying to
do what Christopher Nolan Did in the
Dark Knight trilogy and just have like
scientific explanations for everything
but I believe what made the MCU so great
is that they just leaned into the idea
that there could be Cosmic Gods out
there or worm holes to other dimensions
and [__] like that do you think Sony
would benefit from going more into
Cosmic horror or should just do what
it's currently been doing well that's
it's interesting because when you're
saying Cosmic horror we're we're too
very like to big things so we're talking
like Godly horror we're talking like
can't be contained horror because I'm
like I technically we kind of got
Thriller is horror for
Mobius and uh yeah I what I'm saying by
Cosmic horror is the acknowledgement
that that there are forces in the
universe beyond our control or our
understanding yeah I think the fear
Powers come from the cosmos versus
grounded as like it's some kind of
psychological thing that I'm going
through inter
or you know government experimentation
led to this yeah it I don't it's like
the fear I think that would come from it
is it's such a big topic and it kind of
feels like not that it's the same to
Marvel but it's like if Marvel's kind of
dealing with that right now you kind of
want to stay in your own lane and I
could see Sony being like Oh you know
what's working really well with across
the spiderverse this internalized stuff
let's let's talk more about this and
those fears but I do think with like
null and that situation you're going to
have to come to it eventually that is
our that is your biggest bad that is the
that is what is set up right now there
is no other person in your guys's
universe that is worse than null showing
up and you already have the Symbiote so
it just seems like you should be going
that direction and I think they know
that I think they're planning out ahead
of time and they're doing that and I do
think they're GNA kind of approach the
topic a little bit in Madam web but not
as hard as they're going to hit it in
venom 3 so I think they're afraid of it
but it's it's coming more interested in
who's going to be the one writing it
it's the difference between slash Horror
in like uh ghost stories right like is
your ghost story a Scooby-Doo ghost
story where the ghost is revealed to
actually be a person who's like trying
to take over some real estate um because
that's one form of horror but there's
another form of horror where the person
writing it it's just kind of
acknowledging I don't have an
explanation for where this ghost comes
from and there's just evil in the world
and it comes from outside of us and we
are just potential victims to it so we
have to stay vigilant but there's
another type of horror where it's just
like no sometimes there are just bad
people who do shitty things and that can
be scary to us yes I would love for them
to touch that I kind of think they're
going to touch that kind of horror a
little bit I I suggest that they might
touch a little bit of that Horror in
Madam web if they do include that
villain from like the Ezekiel storyline
that like eats Spider-Man I don't think
they're going to necessarily have
someone literally in the Sony verse
eating a human being but I do think
there is going to be like a Heroes type
of Trope of a super villain that's like
oh I absorb the powers and if he's there
to take like a pregnant Mary Parker
that's dark to be like I'm going to kill
this pregnant woman to get that baby and
I'm like how are you GNA do that with it
not looking horrible like how are you
just GNA make it scary and it won't be
Scooby-Doo is yeah I I think just in
general um if you're going to be doing a
superhero movie franchise like don't be
afraid of going Cosmic um because that's
like why people are there I don't think
that's just like a lesson that the X-Men
movies and the Daredevil movies in the
early years like that's just one thing
they learned is that like you really
limit yourself of just like trying to
ground it it worked for Christopher
Nolan because he is the best filmmaker
working right now if he ever wanted to
expand the Dark Knight franchise Beyond
those three films like we already saw
when he tried to expand it in The Dark
Knight Rises it gets really hard if you
try to like go Beyond Gotham City like
the Superman could not exist in
Christopher Nolan's Universe Green
Lantern could not exist it would just
break his world too much are you saying
that Sony shouldn't go beyond it like
they're gonna go to I they should I
think they should I think they're trying
to just do like simple small stories but
their characters are not simple or small
100% I want to end this with a new
segment that I'm just going to call what
we're watching because like people ask
us like well will you cover this show
will you cover like whatever and I'm
like no probably not on new rock stars
but we're still watching these other
things so I just want to like give
people a chance to like hear us talk
about other stuff so other stuff I've
been watching this week for me I watched
the finale of The Curse I watch True
Detective night country episode one and
I watched the Fargo finale and I have
loved all three of them and I have loved
all three of you like the new um you
like the new Fargo this season of Fargo
this season of Fargo has been freaking
great Juno Temple was so good on this
show John Ham was so good Joe kery was
so good everyone the character of
talking about ITA monk is like my new
favorite character and all the sin Eater
of that show it's just amazing I mean I
didn't watch season 4 the Chris Rock
season I heard it wasn't very good I
yeah I heard my mom told me it wasn't
good I'm trying to catch up on a lot of
stuff to be fair but uh I I just got my
Showtime to watch The Curse because
enough of you guys are talking and
yelling at me about it um I started I
watched the first two episodes I I'm
nervous about watching it I'm like I
have to be in a a good mood not good
mood but like a mood for Nathan Fielder
so I need I'm scared about watching it
it's it's it's an anxiety like so it was
co-produced by Nathan Fielder and Benny
safy and the safy brothers are the guys
who did uncut gems so if you remember
how uncomfortable watching uncut gems
felt this is similar it's like these
guys are experts in in depicting anxiety
and it's just like God you have to be in
the right mood for it it's sometimes
funny it's just such a good satire of
gentrification and white saviorism but
it its finale goes to such a bizarre
absurdest place that that it just breaks
your brain uncut gems the best part was
when the movie was done um I was
stressed sweating and having a hard time
um but yeah I got showtime for that I
watched the first two episodes of hasb
been Hotel on Amazon Prime because I
love musicals and I'm a huge huge fan of
that person's
animations uh on YouTube so I was very
excited for husband hotel and I just
started the brother's son and it is much
violent thing than I thought it
was it's on Netflix with Michelle yo I
was not ready for that but yeah that's
all I'm watching I'm watching I'm
keeping up with this job has us watching
a lot of stuff so I'm like catching up
on a literal like poop ton of uh we'll
leave it there for this week but um let
us know in the comments below what you
think Venom 3 is going to focus on and
whether it should steer all the way into
the heavens to to come face to face with
null or it should be a Multiverse story
or there should just be three Venoms or
maybe there's a third voice in Tom
Hardy's brain that's out there there's
like his voice there's Venom's voice and
there's like a third dormant voice that
comes up and that's three is we'll leave
it there for this episode of the sneak
peek but uh thank you again to air up
for sponsoring this video your flavor
pods have been delicious but it's just
water that I'm tasting but it's like my
brain it's making me think that it's
flavored water this is a wonderful
sponsor thank you and uh follow yes they
have all different kinds of flavor pods
grab one for yourself the description
has the link follow new rock stars on
Twitter follow Jess Lulu Clemens follow
me at eaos and we will see you all next
week thank you so much for watching
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody